I am a Jew so I don't have a lot of
experience with bacon so this is gonna
be my little Jewish cheat wow these are
thick it lacks the crispness that I've
seen in pictures of bacon which just
makes it seem like that I'm just at my
computer looking at pictures of bacon
like crying it is like you're eating a
tire it's a good alternative I guess
like the best alternative is no bacon
when I'm trying to be healthy I'm I like
getting my body right stuff this is what
I eat chicken bacon exists for some
reason I'm kidding
like a tennis ball vibe from this I
don't know why he's fantastic
this is better than my mom's bacon don't
tell her about that that weird
aftertaste though what is that do this
just chicken you're just trying to be
like aren't I crunchy here's what
happened you went for crunch over taste
that was not a good idea
what this doesn't smell anything like
bacon this one it looks like a dinosaur
or like some kind of sea horse or
something yeah it's hard to pull sorry
dude
this is so good fine cheese like beef
jerky we're gonna stop by the gas
station and pick this up on the way to
Disneyland
cool oh wow this this is the only other
bacon all out Oh lamb bacon I love lamb
chop it looks like I'm gonna have
diarrhea instantly oh god no oh whoa
what's going on this one look at how
much fat it is all the fat just turns
into like liquid instantly in your mouth
it's weird dude what is this it feels
like an emoji bacon are you even trying
this looks like a fruit roll-up oh I
like that this is something you get in
elementary school to like put inside
your book this is like one of those slap
bracelets that you put your arm
hot broken oh my dad you sure like ICC's
and then I was like I'm a convert away
from Judaism but like it's good like
it's okay I'd I would I went you kick it
out of bed reading Bakker's turkey bacon
is still the best one and I don't even
really eat meat anymore and I'll tell
you turkey bacon is the boo it will
never be beat I went to a Jewish day
school and I had a teacher one time tell
me that I shouldn't even eat turkey
bacon because another Jew might see me
eat it and be like oh no she's allowed
to eat bacon why aren't I allowed to eat
bacon and then all of Judaism would
collapse